ça n'a rien à voir
très différents
d'habitude je suis clown
je m'appelle pénélope berthier j'ai un
nez rouge un chapeau une perruque et là
je n'ai rien de tout ça c'est comme si
je venais sur scène pour la première
fois je suis ému et impressionné je
retrouve la même sensation que quand je
suis monté sur scène la première fois
j'avais 8 ans j'étais une petite fille
très timide très introverti on aurait pu
penser que me retrouver face à un public
allait me faire très peur ça a été tout
le contraire
je me suis dit que c'était ma place
enfin je me le suis même pas dit je les
ai sentis je me suis sentie exister j'ai
eu la certitude que ce que j'allais
faire
c'était être sur scène et ce jour là je
me suis affirmé à moi-même que je serai
comédienne alors comédienne ne s'est pas
pionnat on se lève pas un matin en se
disant tiens je vais devenir clown
c'est une rencontre à 17 ans je suis
allé voir un spectacle de clown
contemporain
je sais pas du tout ce que c'était des
russes sape l'elysee day un vrai coup de
foudre
là encore je me suis dit enfin j'ai
senti que ce que je devais être ou ce
que j'allais être c'était clown
la première règle du jeu de clown s'est
affirmée il était une fois un caillou
gris
enfin pas tout à fait gris il était un
peu gris noir si oui est ce que je veux
dire
enfin pas tout à fait gris noir en fait
il était gris noir ça tirait un petit
peu vers le marron ce qui avait des
petites pointes comme ça des couleurs
différentes
enfin c'était pas vraiment un caillou en
fait c'était plutôt un rocher par un
bout de rocher
enfin pas vraiment à bout de rocher
c'était un peu un partant voyez un bout
de parpaings alors pas vraiment un
parent pense que c'était pas aussi carré
qu'un bout de parpaings mais ça
ressemblait quand même alors non à un
bout de deux roches comme c'était un
bout de roche détachées enfin voyons pas
très facile pour se l'imaginer
maintenant si je vous dis c'était un
caillou blanc rond lice
d'où moyens la force
l'affirmation cette force je les ai eus
à 8 ans à 17 ans et aussi quand j'ai
rencontré l'homme de ma vie que j'ai
décidé de quitter mes parents et de
partir en argentine avec lui je lai
affirmé avec toute ma naïveté et toute
ma sincérité
l'affirmation est puissante que si elle
est sincère
la deuxième règle du jeu de clown ses
actions alors ça c'est un énorme pavé à
on pousse toujours l'acteur clown à agir
parce que sans action il se passe rien
le caillou blanc était posé sur le sable
t
ça peut durer longtemps
tout à coup le soleil commença à briller
du coup le caillou commence à avoir un
petit peu chaud commença à suez en suant
commencent à se ramollir un petit peu
d'abord de l'intérieur et puis de
l'extérieur puis petit à petit en fait à
force de se ramollir
il devint un petit peu plat et en
devenant un petit peuple là bas il a
glissé doucement sur le sable et puis
petit à petit sur la grève et il s'est
retrouvé au ras de l'eau et puis tout
d'un coup il ya une vague qui est arrivé
qui l'a emporté malgré lui et serait
retrouvée bas au fond de l'eau alors là
il a commencé à paniquer à se dire mais
qu'est ce que je vais faire au fond de
l'eau je peux pas respirer je peux rien
faire au secours et puis la nature est
bien faite donc petit à petit voilà des
branchies ont commencé à pousser puis
après on commence à y avoir des petites
nageoires qui sont apparues et là il
s'est dit ah ça y est je vais pouvoir
m'adapter je vais pouvoir commencer à
partir à l'aventuré et le premier
caillou aquatique est né dans la vie
c'est pareil
être clown hockey être comédienne ok le
devenir ok mais si je mets aucune action
en place pour le devenir
a priori ça risque pas de m'arriver si
je ne mets pas l'action en lien avec
l'affirmation ça marche pas et quelque
chose de très important pour moi c'est
la curiosité et l'ouverture d'esprit un
caillou blanc ça peut paraître sans
intérêt si je m'y intéresse
ça devient passionnant des cailloux
blancs ne rend compte tout le temps dans
la vie si on n'est pas ouvert et un peu
curieux on peut passer à côté de
beaucoup de choses si on les laventure
peut devenir extraordinaire et on
apprend à l'infini et quelque chose
aussi que j'ai toujours appliqué dans ma
vie et le clown fait exactement pareil
c'est la persévérance je fais je refais
je vais jusqu'au bout de mes envies
le clown ne lâche pas sa piste
on dit qu'il creuse sa piste de jeu le
prêt ue aquatique de tout à l'heure ce
serait dommage de l'abandonner juste au
démarrage de son aventure
est-ce qu'il va réussir finalement
engagé avec ses nageoires ce qui va
réussir à respirer ce qui va réussir à
traverser l'atlantique je sais pas à
croiser peut-être un sous marin russe en
perdition passer sous une île volcanique
est ce qu'il va arriver jusqu'à la
statue de la liberté
on aurait envie de savoir
et puis il y a la confiance c'est un
vrai carburant plus on affirme plus on
gagne en confiance et inversement
en faisant confiance à l'action je me
met en mouvement pour aller quelque part
la curiosité et l'ouverture d'esprit
renforce ma confiance
la persévérance et bien la démonstration
de la confiance la confiance est un
muscle à assouplir à entretenir dont il
faut prendre soin des règles du jeu de
clown y en a plein d'autres sont des
règles de vie alors bien sûr elle enlève
ni la peur ni le doute mais pour tenir
tout ça il ya une arme secrète le rire
est temps qu'on peut rire on est libre
et le clown est libre il ne juge pas il
expérimente et puis ils constatent ils
fabriquent sa réalité par l'expérience
vécue en transformant ce qui lui passe
par la tête en actions concrètes comme
je fabrique la mienne en transformant
mon rêve d'enfant en réalité palpable
et si on peut devenir clown
alors tout est possible
ah parce que moi ça fait quand même neuf
minutes que j'attends et bon en général
c'est moi qui compte d'ailleurs en
général il ya que moi donc là il serait
temps que j'arrive
ça va être parfait
déjà je m'adore mais vraiment je m'adore
non mais vraiment je m'adore c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faut que je m'installe tout le monde
voit bien alors c'est vrai ça a rien à
voir c'est complètement différent
oh moi j'adore j'adore j'adore j'adore
cela je me sens existent et je me sens
vivre je me sens moi quoi en fait c'est
ça a commencé bon commencé bon comment
c'est bon bon alors je m'appelle
pénélope berthier c'est moi et alors
donc moi je vais fabriquer ma réalité
mais je vais la fabrique est vraiment
concrètement parce que moi il me faut du
concret sinon bla bla bla bla bla bla je
comprends rien alors voilà donc ma
réalité
d'abord je vais faire un espace pour
m'arrêter là hop
donc c'est sûr le plastique hop là voilà
alors je fais une réalité parce qu'ils
voient ça c'est pénible
j'aurais jamais dû prendre à bord que ça
fait genre mais ça fait pas du tout
c'est pas confort alors la réalité voilà
jules je la fais pas trop grande parce
que je me suis dit je vais pas faire une
réalité immense même si la scène elle
est super g j'aurais pu faire une
réalité de 10 mètres sur 15 au moins un
truc de fou mais après j'ai dit j'aurais
pas assumer tout ça ça va être compliqué
que trop grande réalité après on se perd
on sait plus trop bon voilà alors je
fais une réalité à ma mesure
alors hop je la flèche non c'est très
important parce que après si vous
confondez que la réalité du voisin ou je
sais pas quoi vous faites une autre
réalité roi ohlala moi je n'ai pas du
tout envie de confondre ma réalité avec
celle de quelqu'un d'autre après je vais
me dire non c'est pas la mienne ans plus
tard on allait du thorium imaginer je
fais la réalité du pianiste qui hélas
d'habitude je sais pas jouer du piano
l'angoissé totale bon alors alors
qu'est-ce que je mets un oui alors au
début pour commencer alors l'affirmation
j'affirme donc le caillou cailloux
blancs ça c'est l'affirmation pas faux
mais a il est exactement comme ça ou non
tout à fait dans nos têtes alors très
bon exemple le caillou alors lui il
affirme le caillou toute façon il se
pose pas des questions il tergiverse pas
il est là il est par la sas et de
l'affirmation pure souche à on peut pas
dire le contraire
ensuite action un peu d'action
l'amérique de faire ça les gens
l'adorent que tu as rêvé de faire ça par
action alors après actions armées
ouverture d'esprit ouverture d'esprit
évidemment ouverture d'esprit alors
voilà je bave aux aguets louanges génial
alors que si je ferme joua pas pareil là
je vois pas le caillou vraiment et là
j'ouvre homéo ben voilà trop d'ouverture
trop d'ouverture trop d'ouverture font
pas trop d'ouvertures faut être un peu
quand même hein calé sur le truc alors
ensuite un oui de la persévérance alors
la persévérance faut creuser un là il
n'y a pas le choix
vous creusez vous creusez bon vous
creusez là j'ai pas creuser le dit rien
parce que sinon je revis problème voilà
si jamais c'est dur là vous y allé à la
pêche
hu moi j'ai une petite baisse que j'ai
une valise investi non vous prenez une
énorme baisse on peut prendre des peut
enfin voilà pouvait de labouheyre de ce
qui est des fois c'est durant il faut
vraiment crevé il fort du muscle après
alors à voile et la confiance faut
muscler pour muscler taf assouplir bon
voilà je vais pas le faire pendant trois
heures
ce que ça va deux minutes un confus
c'est fatiguant la confiance
en fait alors après alors après oui
voilà la peur on va mettre un peu de
peur parce que ça n'enlève pas la peur
donc dans l'arrêté de fond d'avoir un
petit peu donc du bois bon ça ça fait
pas super peur à raharaha crocodile
raconte-t-il
ça fait trop peur voilà génial alors la
peur s'est fait après à miami alors je
vais m je vais mettre du tout aussi un
gros doute là un beau grand doute beau
bon gros doutes
c'est un beau gros doutes wild doute je
doute j'ai tout pour interrogation pour
ceux qui voient pas trop bien hop voilà
ça c'est bon alors moi je rajouterais
quelques petits éléments parce que quand
même elle n'a pas tout dit ou dit moi je
mettrais un petit peu de rêve quand même
parce que bon ça fait toujours du bien
je mettrai un petit peu de paillettes ou
ce que moi le spectacle ça me parle quoi
j'avais d'une valeur de l'amour parce
que moi sans amour
ben je sais pas faire alors j'en mets
deux comme ça de l'amour
je crois qu'on est bon alors bon ça fait
un peu de ta comme ça là
piper esthétique a vraiment une fois la
réalité ce pas exactement comme on
l'avait prévu chez port je voulais faire
un truc bofill voilà en fait bon bon ben
j'ai fait ce que je pouvais mais c'est
comme ça bon alors je vais la ramener
avec moi ce que c'est qu'un ma réalité
et l'idée c'est pas de copier un sur ma
réalité ce que chacun la sienne
voilà je prends ma réalité up alors ce
soir vous faites quoi vous prenez ce que
vous avez sur la main et vous fabriquez
la vôtre c'est pas compliqué
[Applaudissements]